ein öl-embargo gegen russland wird seit
wochen diskutiert jetzt soll es nun
kommen wir müssen das einfach tun auch
wenn es schwierig ist so
eu-kommissionspräsident in ursula von
der leyen heute vor dem parlament in
straßburg mit dem sechsten
sanktionspaket als reaktion auf den
angriffskrieg will man russland weiter
schwächen wird das funktionieren und
voraussetzung dafür ist die zustimmung
aller mitgliedstaaten deutschland hat
lange gezögert und für ungarn und die
slowakei soll es ausnahmen geben welche
folgen hat der import stopp für unsere
wirtschaft und für uns verbraucher kein
öl mehr aus russland was bedeutet das
für europa unser thema heute in der
phoenix runde
guten abend ganz herzlich willkommen aus
berlin ich darf meine gäste vorstellen
ich begrüße marlies uken sie
stellvertretende ressortleiterin für
politik wirtschaft und gesellschaft bei
zeit online
herzlich willkommen marc felix serrao
erst chefredakteur der neuen züricher
zeitung in deutschland daher ist das
chefredaktor aber wir sagen einfach mal
chefredakteur damit nicht irritiert
herzlich willkommen professor hubertus
bardt geschäftsführer des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft iw und in brüssel
begrüße ich herzlich michael gritz
korrespondentin korrespondent der ard in
europa studio herzlich willkommen
michael gritz herr größer noch mal mit
ihnen an diese vorschläge der eu
kommissionspräsident in heute jetzt das
öl-embargo doch eben gegen russland
durchzusetzen was bedeutet das was hat
sie da genau vorgeschlagen
also das ölembargo haben sie
angesprochen ich komme gleich darauf
zurück davor vielleicht noch zu erwähnen
es gibt auch noch sanktionen gegen eine
reihe von offizieren die an dem massaker
in butter beteiligt gewesen sein sollen
die sberbank als wichtigste bank
russlands ist auch vom trifft von swift
liste vom zahlungssystem wird es
ausgeschlossen das gilt auch noch für
zwei weitere banken damit will man
möglichst zwei die isolation russischer
banken vom internationalen
zahlungsverkehr erreichen und dann gibt
es eben auch noch das öl embargo und das
bedeutet nach sechs monaten soll es dann
keine ölprodukte mehr geben und bis zum
ende des jahres auch keine raffinierte
produkte und dann kommen aber noch zwei
arbeit das ist nämlich das öl für die
slowakei und ungarn zwei länder die
besonders abhängig sehen von russischem
öl bei denen gilt das alles erst im
dezember 2023
also es wird ein öl-embargo
wahrscheinlich geben denn das ist ja ist
der vorschlag der eu-kommission
allerdings wird das geld an russland
zwischen 500 millionen und einer
milliarde am tag wohlgemerkt also weiter
fließen wird erstmal weiter fließen das
heißt wann kann man damit rechnen dass
das wirklich dann wirkung zeigt die
frage ist ob es überhaupt irgendwann
wirkung zeigt das ist ein thema das sehr
umstritten ist der wirtschaftsminister
robert habeck war am montag hier hat im
hintergrund mit einigen journalisten
gesprochen ich war auch dabei und da kam
auch ein bisschen skepsis durch denn er
sagte wir sind noch nicht ganz sicher ob
dieses paket wirklich klug ist denn
russland wird sich natürlich seine
kunden woanders suchen so wie auch
europa sich andere lieferanten sucht und
die frage ist doch dann wenn insgesamt
das öl deutlich teurer wird wenn es wenn
das embargo den dann wirklich einfach
immer mal wirkt das dann möglicherweise
eben russland anderen ländern anbietet
ihnen öl zu einem discount zu bieten und
die an ihre seite zieht also das ist die
eine frage und die andere frage ist ob
die art dieses embargos wirklich wirksam
ist und ob es nicht andere möglichkeiten
gegeben hätte mit dem öl oder mit den
energieformen russlands umzugehen
sprechen gleich noch mal ausführlicher
frau open wenn sie das so hören sieht
man ja es ist keine leichte entscheidung
hat ja auch gedauert bis deutschland
sich da auch zum durchgerungen hat wie
finden sie diese entscheidung dass man
jetzt doch sagt und dass die kommission
das vorschlägt dass es ein öl embargo
geben soll also ich glaube schon dass
die richtige entscheidung ist wir haben
einmal den pfad eingeschlagen wir haben
ein kohl embargo ja schon auf eu-ebene
das habe ich in drei monaten in kraft
und ich glaube man muss sozusagen diese
droge ist einfach aufrechterhalten wenn
man einmal den pfad eingeschlagen er hat
dann muss sie jetzt eigentlich das
nächste kommt der nächste schritt ist
konsequenterweise immer ein öl-embargo
wir sind längst noch nicht immer beim
gas embargo dafür sind die
voraussetzungen viel zu schwierig und
deswegen finde ich genau richtig jetzt
irgendwie das öl-embargo zwei öl embargo
russland auch härter treffen genauere
ganz genau also russlands staatshaushalt
basiert vor allem aus den einnahmen aus
erdöl wir reden hier die ganze zeit über
gas und denke irgendwie so gas ist
eigentlich von großer bedeutung ist
eigentlich die einnahmen kommen aus dem
erdöl für russland das wird hoffentlich
sozusagen eigentlich putin und das
regime stärker treffen aber ich gebe dem
kollegen in brüssel natürlich recht was
wirklich dann die konsequenzen sein
werden wie putin reagiert das kann
keiner sagen dass eines mit putin
reagiert das andere ist natürlich das
fragen sich ob verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher hier herr professor partie
frage viele fragen sich natürlich welche
auswirkungen wird so ein embargo auf die
deutsche wirtschaft haben was was
befürchten sie da was bedenken sie
es gibt jetzt zwei dinge die passieren
können das eine ist dass die mengen
fehlen die wir für den verbrauch von
euch hier benötigen und da ist jetzt
lange daran gearbeitet worden das
sicherzustellen dass wir im wesentlichen
gemengen zumindest das alles vorher
bekommen die beiden raffinerien in
ostdeutschland sind wir das wesentliche
problem aber die werden zumindest auf
minimaler leistung mitfahren können und
die andere frage ist wie sich die preise
entwickeln werden und das wird
sicherlich ein stück noch nach oben
gehen hier ist die relevante frage wie
saudi arabien reagiert wie also die zu
oft zusätzliche mengen auf dem weltmarkt
mit aufkommen würden aber die
abhängigkeit von deutschland vom öl ist
ja schon gesuchten von russischem erdöl
von 35 auf 12% wenn ich so richtig
gelesen habe das heißt könnte man das
noch weiter sinken oder ist das
sozusagen das ende der fahnenstange
das wird ja weiter singen muss weiter
sinken wenn wir nichts mehr importieren
insofern ist die frage vor allem wie
organisieren wir das was in den großen
ostdeutschen raffinerien verarbeitet
wird die hängen an den alten pipelines
die aus warschauer pakt zeiten kommen
die alte zeit des eisernen vorhangs ist
danach wie vor noch zu sehen und das
kann ich einfach ersetzt werden durch
transporte aus dem laster aus
westdeutschland bringen besser war weg
in warschau um sicherzustellen dass wir
danzig mitnutzen können und also die
mengen scheint auszureichen vielleicht
nicht vollständig aber doch um die
wesentliche produktion sicherstellen zu
können okay sera sera wie sehen sie
wirksam ist denn dieses embargo wärme
jetzt schon diverse punkte gehört wo das
halt eben schwierig ist wie wirksam ist
es als als sanktion gegen den krieg ich
möchte mich der kollegin anschließen und
erstmal grundsätzlich sagen dass es eine
eine sinnvolle maßnahme ist weil
russland ganz entschieden von den
einnahmen aus dem ölgeschäft abhängt das
ist das wichtigste exportgut mit abstand
60 prozent der exporte gehen nach europa
insofern es wird eine wirkung entfalten
ob es am ende die gewünschte wirkung
entfalten wird wird man sehen wurden war
schon die rede davon dass es natürlich
andere abnehmerländer gibt china ist
eines indien die größte demokratie der
welt bezieht auch noch russisches öl und
hat noch nicht erkennen lassen dass sie
das dass sich ändern soll und die frage
ist auch wie sich der ölpreis entwickelt
ich bin da kein experte aber wenn darauf
geht auf ich weiß nicht 150 160 dollar
pro barrel russisches öl erzielt nicht
den weltmarktpreis aber würde dann auch
anziehen dann könnte nachher in der
summe die sorge wurde auch schon
verschiedentlich geäußerten
gar nicht so viel schlechter verdienen
als es heute tut aber das würde dann
wieder sehr dagegen sprechen sie haben
sich ja in einem kommentar auch da er
auch sehr kritisch dagegen geäußert
haben gesagt es kann eben sein dass
dadurch auch die kosten für europa eben
sehr stark erhöht werden das klang nicht
so als würden sie das nicht begrüßen so
einem wagen in einem na ja die frage ist
was will man sonst tun also die hände in
den schoß legen geht nicht und wenn es
deutschland tatsächlich gelungen ist
jetzt die abhängigkeit von russischem öl
auf 12 prozent zu reduzieren die zwölf
prozent sind die raffinerien in schwedt
dann ist das ja einfach schon mal eine
leistung des wirtschaftsministers vor
allem was will man sonst tun beim gas
sind deutschland also vor allem
deutschland er die hände gebunden also
da wären die wirtschaftlichen
verwerfungen
sicherlich sehr sehr viel größer aber
dann machen wir nochmal konkret wenn es
nur an schwedt liegt er bat oder fragen
sie erst mal nachfragen wenn es an
dieser raffinerie in schwedt liegt die
ja eigentlich nur russisches öl
verarbeiten kann da machen sich die so
die menschen in der region natürlich
extreme sorgen genau also für die
menschen in der region da hängt einfach
arbeitsplätze dran ganz einfach gesagt
und dieser gerade spät ist wenn wir
einen industriestandort irgendwie schon
zu ddr zeiten gewesen und diese
artillerie ist einfach so tief
eingegraben und verankert dort in der
region und das ist glaube ich echt für
die regionen waren sie nicht schwerfällt
zu akzeptieren dass man da jetzt raus
muss und ein auge hat einen russischen
besitzer ja genau da draußen genau das
ist ja wie das vertrackte an dieser
ganzen konstruktion das schwert gehört
roßner france
gerade der ölkonzern wo gerhard schröder
von der spd noch noch mb vorsitzende des
aufsichtsrats ist
natürlich gar kein interesse mehr an
einem ölembargo wenn es da die pck
raffinerie
organisiert und deswegen wird glaube ich
jetzt im wirtschaftsministerium
wahnsinnig geradelt um dieses konstrukt
und wir aufbrechen zu können also da
gibt es verschiedene varianten eine
möglichkeit und das schärfste schwert
ist natürlich am ende sogar eine
enteignung
aber ich glaube wir müssen einfach
gerade solche radikalen ideen auch mit
in die überlegung ziehen weil sonst ein
keine andere möglichkeit gibt mw
konsequent das umzusetzen
diese zwölf prozent das ist nur noch
schritt das ist nur schwer okay das ist
hoffen alle dass ich das irgendwie lösen
lässt herr barth oder ist das eher eine
wenn man dann bleiben wir noch mal bei
dieser regionalen bei diesem regionalen
unterschieden wenn man sagen das ist nur
schwer
muss man sagen dann für den rest des top
von norddeutschland ist das alles gar
kein problem oder sehen sie noch andere
probleme bei einem embargo
der selbst selbst wenn es nur steht ist
dann ist das ja die versorgung von
weiten teilen ostdeutschlands mit
mehreren produkten benzin diesel die der
br mit kerosin wird immer wieder genannt
also ist schon wichtig dass wir dort
auch produzieren zumindestens minimalen
mengen produzieren
deshalb war es so wichtig dass nicht zu
überstürzen sondern sich erst zu
überlegen wie können wir denn ersetzen
wie können wir auch entsprechend
produktion sicherstellen und dann zu
sagen ja wir steigen tatsächlich aus das
gilt jetzt in sechs monaten für roll
selber zwei monate später auch für
mineralölprodukte
wo wir wenig hingucken ist dass wir
ziemlich viel diesel aus russlands mit
einführen und der auch ersetzt werden
muss der also durch zusätzliche
produktionskapazitäten
er ersetzt werden muss das heißt es wird
teurer auf jeden fall für die menschen
die an der tankstelle sind
russland ist der drittgrößte
ölproduzent der welt russland produziert
fast so viel erdöl wie saudi arabien und
wenn es gelingen sollte das land zu
wichtigen teilen vom weltmarkt mit
fernzuhalten dann fehlenden mengen die
mengen können ersetzt werden die mengen
können durch andere länder mit ersetzt
werden aber das muss dann auch geschehen
das muss die opec dann auch erst mal tun
und das ist sicherlich noch nicht
sichergestellt
kurz was denken sie wie wie schwierig
wird es jetzt sein dass man sich da in
der eu einigt und dass man wirklich
diesen vor diesem vorschlag der
kommissionspräsidentin dann auch folgt
dass man das wirklich umsetzt also hier
fing ja diese gespräche um dieses
embargo laufen ja schon seit mehreren
tagen es gab am wochenende die
sogenannten beichtstuhl gespräche
seitens der kommission
er wurde dann ein ständiger vertreter
nach dem anderen zu rate gezogen und
gefragt was könnt ihr denn mittragen und
dabei ist dann deutlich geworden dass
ungarn und die slowakei ernste probleme
haben ungarn soll sogar mit einem veto
gedroht haben deswegen hat man beide
länder erst mal ausgenommen also die
uneinigkeit oder ich will es mal nennen
die not in den einzelnen ländern ist
also in diesem paket schon inkludiert
und man hat also diese beiden ländern
hat man eine längere frist gegeben
insgesamt muss ich aber sagen zeigt sich
die europäische union bei allen
unterschieden in den nöten bedürfnissen
ansichten also einig wie schon lange
nicht mehr also es ist zeigt sich zum
wiederholten male dass innerhalb einer
krise die europäische union deutlich
zusammen gerückt ist und deutlich
zeichen setzen kann und sich auch
ziemlich einig ist denn auch aus ungarn
kam ja der wunsch oder die zustimmung zu
einem zu einer sanktion wenn auch nicht
zu dieser speziellen und so schnell
jedenfalls durchgeführt aber im
grundsatz er trägt man das ja mit und
das ist interessant zu sehen also europa
zeigt sich in der tat ziemlich einig und
wenn
putin einst nicht erreicht hat
jedenfalls meiner ansicht nach dann ist
es die europäische union zu spalten das
war immer sein ziel und noch schlimmer
wenn ich mir den kleinen exkurs einladen
darf trifft es ihn aus seiner sicht
wahrscheinlich was die nato angeht denn
die wird sich womöglich erweitern um
finnland und schweden also dass alles
das was er da eigentlich erreichen
wollte ist zumindest was einigkeit
angeht schiefgegangen bislang ja okay
also eine eigentliche einige eu wie wir
sie lange nicht hatte es sarah wie wird
das eigentlich aus der schweiz
beobachtet die gesichter auf stellt auch
jetzt mit dem embargo da möchte ich
gerne vorweg schicken dass ich als
deutscher staatsbürger natürlich nicht
für die schweiz sprechen kann und mein
arbeitgeber eine schweizer zeitung tut
es auch nicht
das ist also wir bei der nzz verfolgen
dieser das sanktionsregime mit
zustimmung nun ist die schweiz
beispielsweise bei google importen aus
russland überhaupt nicht betroffen also
es gibt keine direkten rohölimporte und
es wäre auch bei die schweiz wäre beim
gas nicht annähernd so stark betroffen
wie deutschland ich glaube der
energiebedarf um gas sind 14 prozent die
hälfte kommt aus russland und die
schweizerische industrie ist nicht so
energieintensive die deutsche
interessante debatte die in der schweiz
stattfindet gerade und und die auch sehr
vehement geführt wird ist um die
neutralität der schweiz ja also wie soll
sich die schweiz verhalten
da gibt es unterschiedliche lager die
nationalkonservativen sozusagen eine
sehr traditionelle sicht also die sehen
wirklich sozusagen den schweizer mit dem
hellebarden an der grenze der sich aus
allem raushält und das liberale lager
und auch die kommentierung der nzz sieht
das anders die sagt heid neutralität
bedeutet nicht gleichgültigkeit wir als
schweiz sind mitten im nato gebiet und
müssen uns da unterstützend verhalten
okay das nur mal so als kleiner exkurs
da wir nur von der nz sind aber die
frage wer wen sie auf die idee nämlich
auch bei der schweiz finde ich schon
auch spannende mir dass die schweiz
natürlich ein beliebter standort für die
ganzen rohstoffhändler ist eine also
viele dieser ganzen konzerne die jetzt
betroffen sind unter anderem trafigura
haben ihren sitz natürlich in der
schweiz und die schweizer regierung hat
er ja auch teilweise werden der
besondere rolle gespielt sagt die frage
die wir uns stellen wollen ist wie
wirksam wird dieses embargo sein wie
sehr wird dass russland treffen sie
haben eben gesagt wie wichtig für
russland ist der serie was was glauben
sie wie sehr also welche wirkung kann
dieses öl embargo entfalten
ich hatte vorhin über die möglichen
folgen gesprochen die sozusagen die
erwünschte wirkung behindern könnten
eine ganz zentrale frage ist ja auch
würde sie könnte ein öl embargo dazu
führen dass der krieg vorzeitig beendet
wird und da würde ich ein großes
fragezeichen setzen weil bei dem
aktuellen stand wäre es absolut ein
absoluter gesichtsverlust wladimir putin
das heißt der krieg wird sicherlich
nicht durch ein ölembargo enden er kann
natürlich wenn der wirkung entwendet
wenn es ein paar wirkung entfaltet in
russland das wäre die große hoffnung den
druck verstärken auf einen regime change
weil ich denke er erstmal es erhöht
einfach den ökonomischen druck auf putin
und ist die ganze kriegs finanzierung na
also die einnahmen brechen weg man sieht
das ja jetzt schon welche auswege
versucht werden zu gehen also das öl
wird versucht irgendwie an anderen
länder eben indien oder auch china wird
zu verkaufen und das wird glaube ich
dass erst das ganz konkrete was jetzt
gerade passiert ich glaube regime change
in wir durch die sanktionen zu erreichen
da ich ein sehr ambitioniertes ziel
würde ich denken wäre dass das ziel der
eu michael dass man versucht mit diesem
mit diesem embargo das zu bewirken
ich bin mir nicht sicher ob das das ziel
ist natürlich das vordergründige ziel
ist russland zu schwächen und die
wirtschaft von innen so auszuhöhlen dass
möglichst viele menschen in russland
irgendwann sagen sie tragen dass nicht
mehr mit was die regierung da was putin
da macht aber ob das wirklich diese
wirkung erzielt ich persönlich habe da
ehrlich meine zweifel denn die
einnahmen sind ja bisher noch nicht
weggebrochen denn die einnahmen sprudeln
ja wie ich gesagt habe einfach weiter
wie beziehen ja weiterhin die energie
aus russland und die einnahmen sinken
allenfalls in dem umfang in dem
deutschland oder andere länder weniger
energie tatsächlich abnehmen seitens
russland aber im moment nimmt man
wahnsinnig viel energie abnehmen nur das
beispiel gas denn das ziel ist ja die
speicher möglichst rappelvoll zu kriegen
und das ist ziemlich langsam dauert das
ziemlich mühselig damit man dann für den
nächsten winter gewappnet ist falls
irgendetwas anderes passiert ich will
noch zwei andere sachen hinweisen
erstens es gibt unter vielen ökonomen
jahr die kritik an der art dieses dieser
sanktion an gibt einige die sagen es
wäre viel sinnvoller gewesen nicht ein
öl embargo zu beschließen sondern solle
zu erheben auf russisches öl und
dementsprechend zusatzeinnahmen eben
dann auch zurückzuführen an die
verbraucher beispielsweise also viele
halten das für deutlich wirksamer das
zweite ist die sanktionen kommen sehr
sehr spät das geld fließt wie gesagt
weiter und ob das so seine wirkung
erzielt ich habe da wirklich meine
zweifel es gibt aber
bei zahlen weil man zöller erhebt dann
wäre man ja weiter abhängig von russland
das ist man ja auch so wir sind ja
weiter abhängig das nächste halbe jahr
das nächste dreivierteljahr wir nehmen
ja in kauf dass es diese
übergangsfristen gibt weil diese
abhängigkeit hier besteht also das wäre
so dass olaf h ich will auf eine wirkung
abheben die ich besonders wichtig finde
die vielleicht ein bisschen untergeht
bei dem ganzen das ist nämlich eine
wirkung im binnenverhältnis der
europäischen union ich glaube noch nie
war der druck so groß dass man sich auf
andere beine stellt energetisch
betrachtet dass der die wasserstoff
industrie wirklich voran getrieben wird
das erneuerbare vorangetrieben werden
dass man zusammenarbeitet endlich denn
zwischen vielen ländern ist das noch
längst nicht der fall es fehlen
verbindungslinien für den austausch
beispielsweise von gas der zwischen
spanien und frankreich zum beispiel also
da ist unheimlich viele gegangen was
vorher so schnell nicht in gang gekommen
wäre was viel viel länger gedauert hätte
und diese wirkung dies wirklich
außerordentlich positive eindruck für
die klima- und bänder und beschleunigung
professor bart wie sehen sie was wenn
das beispiel der zelle wäre das ein
punkt wo sie sagen das wäre eigentlich
wirksame
vielleicht erst einmal noch ein wort zu
der frage ob russland eigentlich
betroffen ist oder nicht wir sehen jetzt
schon dass produktion in russland zurück
geht's wir sehen dass russlands nur mit
30 35 prozent abschlag sein öl verkaufen
kann die kapazitäten tanker kapazitäten
öl von nord russlands rund um die
weltmeere nach indien und so weiter zu
bringen ist begrenzt die chinesische
pipeline ist sowieso schon voll also die
möglichkeiten für russland einfach
diesen riesen kunden europa zu ersetzen
uns damit sein geld wieder zu verdienen
die sind schon sehr begrenzt und
insofern wird das russland und sehr
direkt im russischen staatshaushalt
schon treffen der ölpreis ist zwar
insgesamt hoch gegangen aber der preis
für ukraine öl für zu den figuren öl
also russisches öl ist runtergegangen
insofern ist russlands ihr schon
getroffen die frage war jetzt wie
organisiert man das ist das ein zoll es
gab den den eleganten vorschlag eine art
zoll- anzudrohen beziehungsweise zu
sagen wir kaufen öl aus russland es wird
aber nur das bezahlt was die
produktionskosten mit sind alles weitere
geht auf ein sonderkonto und wird zur
finanzierung des wiederaufbaus in der
ukraine ausgezahlt oder ähnliches ist
alles diskutiert worden hätte auch
bestimmte vorteile gehabt aber die die
reduktion der förderung die folgen wird
der reduktion des verkaufs das trifft
russland langfristig weil wir viele
quellen viele anlagen haben die damit
dauerhaft zu stützen verhalte ich mich
dann im portal auch immer gefragt
zurzeit haben wir das gefühl wir
entscheiden aus einer position der
stärke weil wir denken und wir werden
sozusagen öl und gas wir sind die
wichtigsten abnehmern können damit
drohen aber natürlich bei meinem
importzahlen ist natürlich oder bei
jeder reaktion die wir machen auch immer
kann putin natürlich auch reagieren also
warum sollte er ein importzoll zahlen
oder mitmachen also warum sollte er das
embargo mitmachen also die frage ob
putin tatsächlich reagiert oder nicht
reagiert die steht glaube ich bei allen
fragen die wir hier stellen und und die
die eu entscheidet im raum und das haben
wir gesehen in der letzten woche als
dann polen und bulgarien einfach der
gashahn zugedreht wurde weil man da
bestimmte regeln die putin gerne wollte
nämlich diesen sehr speziellen umtausch
in rubel weil die beiden länder das
einfach nicht akzeptiert haben also
dieses dieses risiko ist in der tat
immer da und sie haben natürlich recht
wir reden immer darüber welche
möglichkeiten hat die europäische union
und was kann man hier alles machen
letztlich hängt alles davon ab wie
interpretiert und wie beurteilt der
starke mann in moskau das ganze und
welche reaktionen zeigt er da drauf also
das ist etwas womit man dauernd rechnen
muss und was hier auch die große sorge
in europa ist dass so etwas ähnliches
passiert wie in polen oder in bulgarien
das ist überall zu spüren
also ich wollte nur sagen aber ich würde
ja immer auch sagen langfristig ist die
strategie natürlich genau richtig na
also dass tritt gerade soviel den
hintergrund des wir denken okay wir
wissen auf diese kriegsverbrechen real
will eigentlich eine schnelle reaktion
man möchte gerne schnell russland
treffen und man möchte diesen krieg
natürlich schnell beenden genau aber
gleichzeitig schlagen wir ja wirklich
diese berühmten fliegen gerade mit einer
klappe wir machen uns sozusagen
sicherer vor dem aggressor russland aber
wir tun natürlich eben mit einem öl und
öl stoppt irgendwie auch etwas für den
klimaschutz ja also wir fahren ja runter
weil zu dieser strategie
öl-embargo gas ausstieg gehört ja die
funktioniert ja nur wenn wir
gleichzeitig die erneuerbaren hochgehen
hochfahren und das brauchen wir jetzt
genau auch er wäre ich wollte vielleicht
noch ganz kurz noch eine anmerkung
machen es dem kollegen in brüssel das
ist eine verbreitete haltung in
deutschland das sozusagen als positiver
nebeneffekt des kriegs und die deutsche
energiewende voran kommt da würde ich
doch ein auch noch mal ein fragezeichen
setzen dass also da könnte einiges
dazwischen kommen also wenn die
energiepreise beispielsweise nicht nur
nicht so stark ansteigen wie bisher
sondern noch viel viel mehr dann dürfte
das doch zu erheblichen
gesellschaftlichen verwerfungen führen
das zeichnet sich ja jetzt schon eine
spaltung ab dem land zwischen ost und
west also das ist nicht nur die
betroffene regionen in brandenburg rund
um die raffinerie schwedt sondern es
gibt umfragen umfragen der mdr hat mal
eine gemacht unter seinen hörern und
zuschauern wie viele menschen ich glaube
es waren drei ostdeutschen bundesländern
denn für energie energie embargo gegen
russland sind zwei drittel waren dagegen
das war im märz es gibt umfragen wie
viele menschen in ost und west schwere
waffen lieferungen an die ukraine
unterstützen das sind im osten ist es
auch eine deutliche mehrheit dagegen ist
so und wenn sich jetzt dann die folgen
durch ein solches öl-embargo erst
richtig bemerkbar machen wir haben über
schwebt gesprochen und über die benzin
diesel und kerosin produktion für berlin
und brandenburg also was machen wir denn
wenn dann tatsächlich das benzin an den
tankstellen in diesen beiden
bundesländern auf einmal in den breit
mit den preisen völlig explodiert das
ist glaube ich alles völlig unabsehbar
dann wird so was wie die deutsche
energiewende glaube ich sehr schnell in
den hintergrund treten herr professor
bart was finden sie wie sollte die
deutsche regierung darauf reagieren auch
wenn man dann noch mal den die
unterschiede zwischen ost und
westdeutschland mit in den blick nimmt
sie mal wie sie auf preisänderungen
reagieren soll was was ja jetzt passiert
ist ist dass man dass man
ausgleichszahlungen gibt es ja diese
berühmten 300 euro pro arbeitnehmer und
das macht sinn es macht eigentlich
keinen sinn dass jeder die bekommen
sondern wir sollten die miete bekommen
die darauf angewiesen sind aber vom
grundsatz her ist ein ausgleich für die
betroffenen die stark betroffenen
bevölkerungsgruppen dafür wichtig aber
klar ist auch wir können uns nicht davon
abkoppeln wenn die preise steigen dann
sind das kosten die wir als
volkswirtschaft als gesellschaft zu
tragen haben wo man rechnung von
gemälden kann man die fallzahlen muss
man aber womit rechnen sie also sowohl
für die verbraucher als aber auch für
die industrie mit mit welchen höheren
lasten rechnen sie denn
wir haben keine fixe zahl aber es wird
sicherlich dazu kommen dass noch mal ein
stück weit die
ölpreise ansteigen die weltweiten öl
preise ansteigen je nachdem wie die
anderen anbieter reagieren und das
angebot geht zurück wenn russland
teilweise aus dem markt geht so wenn
sonst nichts anderes passiert steigt der
preis deutlich wenn das angebot in
anderen ländern ausgeweitet wird dann
moderiert sich das wieder und die opec
ist ja nun auch daran interessiert dass
die wirtschaften in den abnehmerländern
weiterflug zu nehmen und weiter öl
verbrauchen
was würden und wie sehr finden denken
sie dass es einen putsch gibt für die
energiewende das was nicht eben gesagt
hat
das ist zwei gezeigt natürlich sind
erneuerbare energien dann auch etwas was
uns von russischen gas russischen öl
unabhängiger macht christian lindner
bezeichnete sie als freiheit energien es
war eine sehr innovative begriff
jetzt haben wir aber sowieso schon ja
eine deutliche beschleunigung des
ausbaus vorgesehen dass schon vor dem
krieg das fällt schwer das noch mal
unbegrenzt weiter zu steigern und
gleichzeitig fehlt ja eine dicke seile
der energiewende der übergang war mit
darauf basiert dass es günstiges gas aus
russland mit gibt und das steht völlig
in den sternen ob das weitergeht oder
günstig wird es jedenfalls nicht mehr
sein also sofern steht die energiewende
auch vor riesigen herausforderungen oder
die dekarbonisierung vor riesigen
herausforderungen das wird nicht
einfacher durch durch die situation die
wir jetzt haben gespannt ist toll dass
so etwas eine sekunde
nur kurzer spannende ist ja wirklich das
habe ich die bürgerinnen und bürger
diese energiewende schon viel mehr
sozusagen
internalisiert haben und umsetzen
vielleicht auch als die große politik na
also die nachfrage nach solaranlagen auf
privat dächern wärmepumpen irgendwie bei
neubauten die ist ja enorm gerade also
ob eine menge lieferschwierigkeiten auch
durch den krieg durch die lieferketten
die nicht mehr so funktion genau aber
man merkt ja sozusagen irgendwie so beim
bürger passiert auch so was also der hat
das glaube ich auch schon verstanden
dass langfristig oder für ihn dann
vielleicht an wie sehr sehr viel
kurzfristiger der weg in die
erneuerbaren gehen also die bereitschaft
ist da die frage ist eben wie ist dann
wirklich umgesetzt werden genauso wie
herr barth sagt einfach auch eine frage
der kosten dann
teile natürlich die ansichten auch vom
kollegen der nz gucken wir einfach mal
nach frankreich da haben gerade doch 40
prozent der wahlberechtigten eine frau
gewählt die ganz offen mit putin
koaliert wie ich mal sagen wenn die
gewonnen hätte dann hätte er mitten in
europa eine vasallen gehabt die seine
interessen vertritt also insofern ich
glaube ich bin ja nicht naiv was
sozusagen die spaltung fragen angeht
aber um auf die erneuerbaren noch mal
ganz kurz einzugehen es gibt ja auch ein
paar andere länder noch in europa und
die schreiten deutlich stärker voran als
es in deutschland der fall ist ich sehe
nur spanien was dort in sachen ausbau
von solarenergie von produktion von von
wasserstoff angeht da sind enorme
bemühungen im gang ich sehe die
niederlande wo das größte wasserstoff
projekt europas mit 20 gigawatt schon
seit einigen jahren gestartet ist also
da passiert eine ganze menge und
vielleicht ist auch die deutsche etwas
lahme perspektive auf dieses thema da
dauert es ja doch alles sehr lange
verstellt den blick ein wenig über das
was in anderen ländern tatsächlich in
dieser frage schon passiert allerdings
ich weiß es ist natürlich sehr
kompliziert weil alle länder daran
beteiligt sind und weil man da
aufeinander angewiesen ist und dies
alles erst zusammenbringen muss aber
morgen beispielsweise gibt es eine
unterschrift ähnlich analog zur batterie
allianz vor einiger zeit wo die
elektrolyse industrie europas mit der
kommission zusammen sitzt um die
produktion von elektrolyseur nach oben
zu treiben weil man weiß das ist
dringend notwendig bis hin zu ländern in
afrika die photovoltaik ausbauen mit dem
ziel wasserstoff nach europa zu liefern
wie sie nach australien mit denen
verträge gemacht worden sind also da ist
noch mehr unter druck
das nicht missverstanden zu werden der
der druck das zu beschleunigen ist
natürlich gestiegen und das
offensichtlich geworden dass man im
infrastrukturausbau auch dafür schneller
werden müssen es ist dennoch nicht
einfacher geworden und es wird uns vor
allem nicht kurzfristig unabhängig
machen von russischem öl und gas das ist
auch kurzfristig sind das kleine kleine
beiträge die natürlich auch wichtig sind
aber es ist erst mal ein ein switch
fossile zu fossile oder zu fast genauso
viel fossilen die wir den wir jetzt
gleichzeitig mit sicherstellen müssen
und wir bleiben ja halt eben so stark
abhängig von russischem gas das wäre
nochmal meine frage bei der nummer drauf
es müsste man dann nicht jetzt
konsequenter auch schneller ein gas
embargo beschließen wenn man sagt man
macht oelmann will wirklich russland
treffen
ja schön wärs wenn
ich die experten richtig verstehe dann
ist es sehr viel schwieriger
gasimporte zu ersetzen als öl am
weltmarkt und wie gesagt die
abhängigkeit der deutschen industrie vor
allem der deutschen chemieindustrie vom
gas aus russland ist gewaltig also es
gibt da diese die warnung vor allem von
basf in ludwigshafen was das für
kaskaden effekte auslösen würde also
eine schwere rezession
es gibt ökonomen die halten
modellrechnungen dagegen und sagen ach
das ist alles handhabbar aber ich würde
doch sozusagen dazu neigen den
vertretern der industrie jetzt dass
nicht alles murks zu halten was sie
sagen umfragen wir noch mal vereinbart
nach erbach ist öl händelbar aber gas
nicht mehr für die industrie
wenn wir jetzt das gemacht was am
einfachsten ist nämlich der dass cola
embargo dann haben wir jetzt das gemacht
was den größten hebel hat die größte
wirkung auf russland haben kann nämlich
das ölembargo ist das gas embargo oder
die
verzicht auf russisches gas das ist das
was für uns am schwierigsten ist weil es
pipeline gebunden sind weil wir nicht
einfach weil die infrastruktur fehlen
und weil die angebote auf dem weltmarkt
fehlen um das schnell auf andere weise
ich hierher zu bringen sowie das palmöl
möglich ist und deshalb ist das bei gas
dauert das länger ist das schwieriger
dann reden wir über jahrzehnte nächstes
jahr je nachdem wie schnell es gelingt
diese schwimmenden
naja bye bye bye reden wir über monate
bei gas reden wir über viele monate er
über über jahre da ist die frage wie
schnell gelingt das schwimmende
plattform oder schwimmen der
realisierungs anlagen zu kriegen mit
denen dann flüssiggas was man vielleicht
auf dem weltmarkt kriegt dann auch
tatsächlich anlanden und deutschland
verteilen zu können ja auch die frage
wie lange so ein herr beck ministerium
dieses tempo und dieses pushen wie
durchhalten kann also zurzeit hab meine
rosen sie denn dann widerstände im
moment ja ich glaube einfach widerstände
ganz sozusagen fall gesagt wie lang kann
man so auf anschlag das durchziehen also
gar nicht jetzt das lobby widerstände
gibt sondern einfach die liegen ja ein
wahnsinns tempo oder vor jahren machen
in oster paket ein sommer paket herberg
reist durch die welt und versucht wie
verträge abzuschließen ist sind laufend
gespräche mit den betroffenen konzern
jetzt wird noch mal haben wir glaube ich
zwei milliarden in die hand genommen und
eben diese schwimmenden lng terminals da
in der nordsee im jadebusen zu
organisieren und das also ich wir sind
ja selbst schon fast erschöpft irgendwie
von diesem tempo und wie sehr so zu
sagen können die akteure selber das
weiterhin durchziehen und welche möglich
also wann ist man auch beschränkt
budgetmäßig aber eben ja auch an die
kapazitäten also es gibt glaube ich
insgesamt 46 von diesen schwimmenden lng
terminals und die sind jetzt heiß
begehrt aber die kosten auch glaube ich
200.000 dollar am tag und das muss man
sich halt auch leisten das ist eben auch
die frage wie viel geld man dafür hat
wir kennen man dafür auch in die hand
nehmen will wie teuer kann das ganze
werden was denken sie es egal wie sehr
ja dann auf der ordner ist natürlich
auch entlastungspaket all das soll es ja
geben damit steigende preise auch
aufgefangen werden also gibt's
befürchten sie dass es irgendwann so ein
punkt wo man sagt dass das können wir
uns nicht mehr leisten weder so ein
öl-embargo noch ein gas embargo kann es
aller schrecken des krieges die frage
werden wahrscheinlich die vom gas
abhängigen wirtschaftsakteure alle für
sich jeweils beantworten müssen es ist
ja nicht nur ein möglicher
lieferstopp es kann ja auch eine
preisentwicklung geben die dann
bestimmte unternehmen dazu zwingt sich
vom markt zu verabschieden das wird die
großen wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell
treffen wie manche mittelständler aber
wie weit der kreis da steigen wird dass
das kann ich nicht abschätzen wie
würden sie es einschätzen wenn wir sagen
es braucht ja einige monate für das
öl-embargo dann noch länger für das gas
embargo aber so dass man wie lange ist
der atem der eu der kommission und auch
der bürgerinnen und bürger um diesen ja
um weiter halt eben gegen russland
diesen druck aufzubauen
also erstmal zum thema gas also das
steht hier lange lange lange nicht auf
der agenda bevor man mit einer weiteren
sanktionsmaßnahmen in diese richtung
kommt bei allem was ich hier höre was
das öl angeht wird in der tat schon das
schwierig genug werden da haben die
vorredner einiges zugesagt und das teile
ich auch der atem der europäischen union
ist allerdings meines erachtens doch im
moment sehr klar oder auch durchaus
langanhaltend weil mein eindruck in
brüssel ist dass die die das erschrecken
über das was passiert so groß ist dass
man nie wieder zu diesem status quo vor
dem krieg zurückkehren wird und schaut
möglichst unabhängig zu werden in
möglichst vielen bereichen das trifft
nicht nur die energieversorgung schon
während der korona krise ist vielen
deutlich geworden dass man nicht mal
genügend eigene masten besorgen kann aus
eigener produktion und auf an angewiesen
war auch da hat ein umdenken
stattgefunden also da sortiert sich die
europäische union meines erachtens schon
ein stück neu aber natürlich das haben
die vorher schon gesagt das dauert alles
furchtbar lange und da müssen sich alle
hier beschleunigen da passiert auch viel
aber ob das schon ausreicht dafür gibt
es doch sehr viele interessen
unterschiedlicher art so dass man in der
tat einen sehr langen atem braucht und
wie lang der dann ist und auch von den
bürgern mitgetragen wird da bin ich auch
über fragen also das kann ich
vielleicht nur eine anmerkung ich fand
das interessant dass sie sozusagen die
die einigkeit der europäischen union nur
mehrmals schon betont haben ich glaube
dass überhaupt ein öl-embargo möglich
ist liegt daran dass deutschland sich
bewegt hat also unser korrespondent in
brüssel hat glaube ich sinngemäß
geschrieben wenn deutschland sich bewegt
bewegt sich in der regel die eben wenn
deutschland da blockiert hätte wäre gar
nichts passiert und deshalb passiert
auch nichts beim gas und ich glaube
deshalb wäre deutschland gut beraten in
den jetzt anstehenden diskussionen über
das öl embargo über die sorgen der
länder die da auf die bremse treten
nicht hinweg zu gehen der deutsche
wirtschaft das ist richtig dass es
ausnahmen gibt für ungarn für die
slowakei wenn wir die abhängigkeit ist
eine ganz andere ich glaube da ist jetzt
zum teil der abhängigkeit von 5 75% 100
prozent und robert habeck der wie ich
finde ansonsten in puncto politischer
kommunikation wirklich einen
beachtlichen job macht mitunter rutschen
ihm dann dinge raus die schwierig finde
also wenn dann von widerspenstigen
ländern spricht nicht wahr also
deutschland ist was das angeht auch
wieder spenden
erwartet würden wie beurteilen sie das
agieren des wirtschaftsministers also
wohl in der kommunikation als auch jetzt
im jahr in diesem voran gehen dass man
sagt man ist dann doch bereit auch zu
diesem öl embargo
ich habe er macht tatsächlich einen
guten job die regierung machen ein guten
job an der stelle das ist nicht
überstürzt das ist nicht aus der nicht
auf die schnelle auch öffentliche
reaktionen da einfach drauf reagieren
sondern es ist es wohl durchdacht und
man hat klar gemacht wir wollen erst
organisieren dass wir ein solches
embargo auch durchhalten können dass es
gelingen kann dass wir ersatz haben
bevor man es dann beschließen will und
tatsächlich dazu kommt und das will ich
will ich sehr richtig und wichtig dass
genau so rum zu machen und mich anders
rum das ist ja interessant dass sie das
was den punkt betrifft sagen das ist
sehr positiv viele kritisieren ja beim
kanzler seine sonne etwas dass es sich
bei ihm etwas länger dauert mit den
waffenlieferungen und all diese
entscheidungen die die
entscheidungsfindung ist dafür erntet er
ja viel kritik fragen wie wie sehen sie
den unterschied auch im agieren von
herweck und scholz in richtung ukraine
na ja ich glaube schon dass sozusagen
habe kann das alles vorbereiten und wenn
wir die ganzen voraussetzungen schaffen
und verträge abschließen und die
alternativen ausloten aber am ende so zu
sagen gibt es das gros aus dem
kanzleramt mw das
so zu sagen er ist einfach auch harbeck
ist in dem sinne halte auch abhängig
natürlich was das kanzleramt dann will
und entscheiden ich wollte nach ganz
kurz ergänzen was ich jetzt so wichtig
finde ist ja man kann so sagen und da
haben sie sicherlich ein punkt
irgendwelches wichtig innerhalb der eu
jetzt auch eben die widerspenstigen
kräfte wie hp exilant irgendwie
einzugehen das glaube ich auch total
entscheidend jetzt einmal den blick zu
weiten und vor allem jetzt indien und
china nicht aus den augen zu verlieren
weil wenn wir europa sagt okay wir
machen jetzt ein öl-embargo dann ist
total wichtig dass man halt mw dass
dieses embargo nicht unterlaufen wird
von eben anderen staaten und deswegen
muss man unglaublich diese woche die
deutsch indischen
regierungskonsultationen haben war
sicherlich auch ein wichtiger punkt aber
genau das ist genau ein beispiel dafür
wie man versucht zu sagen gerade
irgendwie jetzt auf seine seite zu
ziehen weil man so weiß dass die haben
einfach ein interesse an günstiger kohle
an günstigen öl die brauchen das jetzt
einfach gerade auch angesichts der
hitzewelle ganz angebot an sowieso und
deswegen muss man jetzt unbedingt die
auf die seite 10 wieso damit die unseren
ambitionierten embargo plan nicht
torpedieren wenn ich vielleicht auch
noch eine anmerkung machen darf weil sie
den direkten vergleich gemacht haben
zwischen dem kanzler und dem
wirtschaftsminister also ich finde er
ist was die politische kommunikation
angeht wirklich eklatant also wer jetzt
der kanzler und habe der kanzler hat im
zdf am montagabend den schönen satz
gesagt die ukraine dürfen nicht
verlieren und russland hier finde ich
gewinnen das ist schön aber was heißt
das denn eigentlich und hat auch sonst
fröhlich herum veranda habe behauptet
deutschland seit das größte land der eu
das ist es nicht hat behauptet
deutschland soll hätte das stärkste
militär was ist denn mit den
französischen britischen
atomsprengköpfen also das war wirklich
wert wenn man da habeck daneben setzt
wenn der erklärt was in schwedt los ist
dann versteht es wirklich der letzte und
vielleicht noch eine anmerkung ich mein
als der ins amt gekommen ist da hieß es
seien auch gesprochen das ist irgendwie
so ein verträumtes landei der wird davon
überfordert seien und nun legt er in
einem tempo los da gebe ich der kollegin
recht das wirklich beachtliches und
sollte es ihm gelingen federführend als
wirtschaftsminister den standort zu
retten dann könnte glaube ich in ein
paar jahren als kanzlerkandidat antreten
ok wird in brüssel gesehen hättest wie
wegmann da darf agierendes
wirtschaftsminister sie haben diese
woche erlebt und und dann aber auf der
anderen seite auch des kanzlers also
sieht man da das deutschland- oder
wünscht man sich nur ein noch stärkeres
voran gehen darf an deutschland also ich
brauche gar nicht viel zu sein kollege
hat es gerade genau so geschildert und
genauso wird es hier wahrgenommen robert
habe kennen wir viele an den lippen und
sind verwundert darüber welche
politische kommunikationsfähigkeit er
hat wieder diese dinge zusammenfasst ist
wirklich sehr interessant und bei olaf
scholz ist es ein bisschen schwieriger
und das sehen halt in vielen anderen
ländern viele andere ähnlich und äußern
ist aber nicht in der deutlichkeit
weil man immer noch unterstellt
deutschland überlegt und ist auch in
zwingern und weit und nimmt man auch
rücksicht darauf aber diese
unterscheidung die wir gerade gehört
haben die wird auch in brüssel so
geteilt und dass man noch mehr wünsche
hat noch mehr vor und das ist
deutschland da noch eine stärkere rolle
spielt
also das ist
das ist schwierig weil da haben alle
wirklich sehr sehr unterschiedliche
interessen so dass keiner da direkte
forderungen an irgendwen ersetzt bei den
rüstungsfragen ist das in teilen noch
mal ein bisschen anders aber der in
osteuropa hat man natürlich viel
stärkere forderungen weil man auch viel
mehr angst davor hat dass russland weil
es ein direkter nachbar oder erfassten
direkter nachbar ist da will man von
deutschland viel viel mehr in anderen
ländern wenn man nach spanien oder
portugal guckt da hat man dann schon
wieder ganz andere interessen weil man
sagt lasst uns bloß nicht in diesen
krieg hineingezogen werden also das zu
verbinden das ist die große kunst und
das ist nicht ganz einfach und sie
rechnen aber damit dass dieses
sanktionspaket so einstimmig beschlossen
wird ich gehe davon aus denn wie gesagt
es ist am wochenende schon lang und
breit vorbesprochen worden ungarn und
slowakei die großen kandidaten die
eigentlich dagegen wahnsinn weitesten
teils ausgenommen und die reaktionen die
man heute aus ungarn das hören können
waren jetzt auch nicht so als dass man
sagt nee das können wir überhaupt nicht
mittragen also ich gehe davon aus dass
das so oder so ähnlich in laufe der
woche noch durch gibt okay wir werden
das weiter verfolgen vielen dank michael
kreuzer nach brüssel herr barth nach
bonn fahren und hersteller für die
diskussion vielen dank ihnen fürs
zuschauen morgen machen wir nochmal
drehen wir noch eine schleife sozusagen
in richtung dieses themas und fragen uns
nämlich eigentlich wer das alles
bezahlen soll all die entlastung und
wende mich vieles teurer wird was wir
alle merken wie viel der staat
aufbringen kann und ob es vielleicht
dann auch eine steuerdebatte gibt seien
sie wieder dabei freue mich bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]